[Music]
i'm going to click on whatever the
youtube algorithm recommends me
no matter how dark and deep it gets and
today
no more edgar can that's right maya cam
say hello to maya cam much better she
does not fall asleep
during my videos isn't that right maya
yeah okay
i'm actually really excited about this
because i've been collecting clips for a
very long time
it's just clips that for some reason
youtube algorithm has been like
you you want to watch this video trust
me guys
you want to see this uh this first one
is martial catches felix it's got a
million views
jesus christ on a random ass channel
i know what this is
don't kill me i was so into it
don't judge me
was that funny maya she's still
processing what she just wanted
i saw the i saw the lights and thought
that
there were candles i generally thought
felix was trying to summon something
yeah okay please don't tell me i'm the
only one who thought it was playing
tambourine
little did she know he was beating up
enemies no i was not
stop it oh my god jesus christ
how 10 million on a random ass
channel
oh i'm sorry am i bothering you you're a
fan favorite you need to
own up to it
[Applause]
percent of the time they arrive and i
send them back because they just oh i
know where this is going
so with this we're gonna hear felix in
this video
i apologize about that
[Music]
this is because we were in japan the
wolves were like non-existing in the
room
but man just got to scream sorry boy i
ain't give a [ __ ] i'm always so scared
that i'm gonna get kicked
out whenever we're renting a place but
for some reason i still commit to the
screams don't die
maya are you enjoying this
mushashi 10 million views that's like
really good for my channel and this
random ass channel hit 10 million
congrats
head society you did it oh this is cute
look maya this is edgar getting scared
of tamarind
oh you're scared you're not tambourine
gang
try it
[Laughter]
sorry oh
that's so cute you're not tambourine
gang
try it the next day breaking news
youtuber strikes again this time he puts
animals in
uncomfortable situations peter is
shocked
oh god i'm doing it again aren't i maya
you enjoy this right
don't do anything if you enjoy this
yeah all right that's that'll say now
the real question
that is my escaro tambourine my you're
not
you can't sleep right now why don't pugs
are so lame they just sleep all the time
dude
that's kind of cute come on all right
maya we need to show
do you get scared of tambourine or not
are you a chad or a beta like
edgar i would guess chad but
she literally does not care everyone
complaining about her nails she's old
okay
her blood vessels goes all the way out
she'll start bleeding if we cut him too
short
and we don't want her in pain sue me
okay what song should
she play
[Music]
hey
all right i'm sorry it is not enough
maya cam i think she gets to chill you
get to chill maya
she's old okay she's earned it evga
however deserves to get terrorized
look you can see her a little bit oh
wait i have another camera
yes this is weird dude all right maya
cam sorted
i it'll do all right next up only 20 000
views does nothing
it's not comfortable
this channel has 126 subscribers but
they get a video with
15 000 views like that's pretty good
hey i forgot about that
is everything surrounded by tambourines
nowadays
okay uh what the [ __ ] is this i have not
seen this
pewdiepie loses his beard while eating
spicy wings
flying kitty i mean what's up dude what
the [ __ ]
hey what's going on everybody for free
feast i'm sean evans and you're watching
hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter memes thanks for the chair
sean evans
he's the meme lord behind youtube the
second full-length project
lasagna absorbed to the top of the
itunes charts earlier this year
hey there's more new memes on the way
welcome to the show
this reminds me of my childhood when i
was a young boy
well how are you with hot it makes me
sick
it makes me wanna myself for views
disgusting
guess what you smell like ass
[Music]
it's time to eat some chicken i've
always wanted to go on hot ones i love
spicy food
literally it does nothing to me anyone
complaining about spicy food is a child
or a woman a week which is either or
damn dude stop
what's the closest you've ever been to
getting your ass beaten
i i used to eat my own ass boy
what do you see as the biggest
misconceptions about ass beaten
damn dude stop asking me this deep
questions
this is pretty much how it would go down
anyway that looks tasty
what's the difference between and
lasagna i don't know
no one knows no one knows i'm not joking
at all i want to die
go on so we have a recurring segment on
our show called the harlem
we do a deep dive in our guests [ __ ]
and then pull interesting pictures from
their instagram does that sound good
no oh
yo those shoes are fire i want those
legs no i don't know
i don't know damn the photoshop i don't
know
well how about this
i don't know perfect
so this is the last step we call it the
last dead
because that's hot i feel like i'm
watching the whole episode if i ever go
on there would be no point i guess
this is already better during a video
and how long did it take to clean up
how would i know do you think
unconscious when i make videos
yeah i am unconscious when i make my
videos thank you all right
2.8 not bad flying kitty congratulations
smash like subscribe to
kitty uh pewdiepie and marsha being
soft i'm not soft all right i'm not a
sim let's play rocket league with
martial
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you
what a woman do you know i'm not soft
ghost oh
ironically right after what she she gave
me a protein bar and g fuel what else
can you want from a wife come on
everyone just simply on mars says
understandable
oh this is another clip from the stream
42 000. so
good i love this people in boston i was
hoping someone was going to re-upload
this
did you guys hear that yeah i'm sorry
maya
look
do you want to fart go away do it this
is your time
this is your chance to fart come on it
would be so funny
sad sad here's another video that's been
recommended to me i don't know why
it's someone filming me markiplier and
jack skating with their girlfriends
wow am i doing it that's me i'm doing
like a dancing
god i'm unfunny jesus christ help me
oh peter's there too
[Music]
who's filming
hey girl peter's almost falling on
his face also appears agro i'm smooth
all right so some random channel
uploaded this
and i got 81 000 views oh here it is
here it is
oh so he's the one that did it a legend
[Music]
okay what do you think of this one man
yes
[Music]
it never ends you know i don't claim any
of these videos by the way i like if you
guys want to re-upload stuff i don't
really care
i hate the whole acclaimed system
already i don't want to play into it
like unless you blatantly rip something
off i'm not going to claim it
but like this is what i hate about
youtube because if this person uploaded
anyone else's
it would have been automatically claimed
that it's like you did that you deserve
that money for the ads or whatever
i hate how it works
[Music]
legend legend can we get a part two atti
wester
please please pewdiepie reacts to ai
channel
i forgot about this
[Music]
oh it's so weird hearing japanese people
turn speak swedish
it's like watching vinland and saga
[Music]
the pronunciation
oh that's funny i forgot about that one
million views
i want one million views this is not
fair right maya the game is rigged
22 million views
and it's a pewdiepie anime gamers
it's minecraft i mean it's so good you
deserve it what a cow
still here of course wake up jeff wake
up there you are
friends here cow is here very epic time
the cows
have done their farm shut up shut up
oh my god he found someone no one leaves
this beach until you two have framed let
that be clear
sven what are you doing there oh man
this takes me back
wait for me sven remember
if you're ever lost just look for ikea
tower and you'll find your way back home
okay
kitty you're going in the bucket you
have no saying kitty you're going in the
bucket you're going
what i remember where's here again
you did this
[Laughter]
[Music]
no you look at sven
this is what happens think about it was
it worth it
was it worth it i didn't do anything i'm
innocent why would you spit on me
i spit on you filthy collections
are you kidding me are you kidding me
are you kidding me
[Music]
forgot how good that was damn well done
i'll take 22 million views
hello tiny horse this is amazing
oh you have to build a shelter before
night
[Music]
dude there's a dog thing there's a dog
don't look at it maya you're important
too trust me i love you i love you
he needs a name sven
crazy we're going so fast
[Music]
don't worry we're going to get you out
of here oh my god
i'm so sorry
someone has earned a little snack sven
yes
that's right i love you
that's right you switch we'll never
despawn
i gotta go back in the minecraft game
cool sven can teleport that's good for
them let's find the again these people
are trying to swing the line
right like the windy we're coming man
stay there i'll be right back
oh god sven is there right now
i was hoping maybe he ran back home
when you're far away from
[Music]
hey it's dan thanks for watching well
done dan it's up to dan
boyz that was fun i know i don't know
why i was going down the youtube rabbit
hole
but that was it thank you oh oh a little
stretchy
oh oh you're tired weren't you i'm
sorry to me
like and subscribe for more videos
upload almost every day
and if you enjoy you made it this far
i'm sure you'll enjoy
more that's it see you tomorrow say bye
bye
bye bye goodbye mortals don't no longer
care for you
crotch cam crotch cam
sorry this is good should i make my
videos like this from now on
hey bros how's it go how's it going bros
my name is sorry
let's end it the angle looks weird i
have really strong legs trust me
look at this all right i mean i don't
have legs wait
barry is still level one and you haven't
fed
bob god damn sickness
get only 19 year olds because their new
trials mode
is like use your full pixeling research
to defeat as many enemy waves as
possible
download pixel links instantly for 20
muscle increase oh